When you, you've crushed your daily to do list,
do you then take the time to relax or do you tack the next days list?
Is that against prioritize and execute since the mission is done for the day,
you know, just do more. Just keep going. Even if it's on the next day,
I keep going do more. If you have extra time,
do whatever you can do to stay ahead.
And I do that pretty much until I'm brain dead. And I, I,
I can definitely work myself into, but until I'm brain dead,
like I can get to a point where I'm reading or I'm writing and it's just,
it's just, it's just done. I'm done.
And so I just have to stop and take a break and then I'll go do something
mindless for awhile, you know? So you know, if you, if you've got stuff to do,
keep hammering until you can't hammer anymore and then say, oh, okay,
you know what?
I need a little breather and then take a little breather and then get back to
it. Right now I could work 24 hours a day, 24 hours a day,
seven days a week, 365 days a year and,
and I wouldn't be able to get done the things I'm trying to get done,
so it's not like I'm sitting there going, oh cool, I've got a break. No.
All I see is all he's got is more stuff to do. You've got things to do.
So not a bunch of boys. You call it breaks and relaxing. That's not a,
not a lot of that happening right now. Now you go surfing. Is that a break?
Kind of. It's like a big,
well it's kind of hard of the process.
It's like if you're doing five sets of 10 on the bench,
what are you going to do? One set of 50 no,
you do five sets of 10 so for a set of the 10 what do you do?
You get a rescue to recover. That's what surfing is. That's the,
it's the rest between sets. That's all that is right there.
You go as part of the process track, but what would you,
would you recommend for someone who's like a normal person?
Do what? You can. Knock it out. Build up extra free time if you need a break.
Take a break. Gotcha. That's pretty crazy, right?
Know what I'm saying? Is Do what you can. If you need a break, take a break.
If you need a little relaxation, take some relaxation.
Don't waste your time though. See, people, people do relaxing, but they do it.
They don't even do it. Good. They don't even feel relaxed when they get done.
It's not productive. Relaxing. Yeah, they're, they just,
what they did is they did something stupid for an hour.
They watched youtube videos for an hour. Did that help? You know, called side.
Go for a run, do some burpees, go surfing, go do some Jujitsu. Uh,
play with your kids, whatever. Do something that actually has some value.
The real value.
Oh, but so what about, you know, [inaudible] Ohana and we're going to,
uh, the bar. Yeah, that's not great,
but sometimes don't get too hammered because you're hung over the next day.
You can't accomp you know, you can't function as good. Boom. Can't, uh,
your output, your productivity goes down next day.
You better tell everyone what pounder means. Cause not everyone knows like, oh,
Pahata I guess technically it means done with what you're doing.
Pop means done. Hahna means like do. Yeah. Um, but yeah,
Paul Hahn, upon finishing with what you're doing, tip,
it's referred to when you're finished with work. Yeah.
That's the way I always used it. You Go, yeah, when you finish work,
Paul Hahna goes, you know, whatever. It's like Miller time, you know,
for sure the same thing a little bit.